[Applaudissements]
méga star en france et dix de prêt taux
est aussi de plus en plus populaire au
québec mais qui est il vraiment je pense
que c'est là le plus important
de l'émotion et de l'humanité s'est
montrée justement ses faiblesses et
questionnement la dégaine vocal du jeune
homme de 25 ans ne laisse personne
indifférent ouvertement gai il aborde
sans détour les thème de l'homophobie et
de la virilité physique j'étais un peu
comme construit par des injonctions qui
mord donnait à être un homme que je
n'étais pas donc robuste vaillant fort
puissant muscles yquem faire le sport
qui ne pleure jamais j'étais un petit
garçon qui était un peu plus sensible un
peu plus dans la sensation et par besoin
de conformisme j'ai gardé ça garder ça
jusqu'au jour où je l'aï écrit sur cet
album
[Musique]
artiste de son temps il utilise son
iphone sur scène pour lancer ses
tristesses j'aime beaucoup la seule
erreur challenge comme ça vous faut se
dépasser ou faut y aller et donc l'idée
de n'avoir rien sur scène avec juste la
relation mois public ça crée une
motivation et donc du coup le téléphone
a aidé beaucoup à ce moment ma miss
toute allure domino ta posture du caïd
mais les gens qui viennent pour le mot
il ya des gens qui viennent pour le
rythme et des gens qui viennent pour la
mélodie
il ya plusieurs motivations et ça se
ressent dans un public assez éclectique
c'est quoi ces tumeurs mammaires entre
fragilité et phobies et 10 de prêt tôt à
se trouver en très peu de temps un sens
qui résonne pour plusieurs générations
une rareté ici julie jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal
j'ai pas compris les cartes
les seuls que si j'ai pas comme ça
je ne